brice hortefeux vice président de l'ump
et tête de liste aux prochaines
élections européennes dans votre région
massif central est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
et dailymotion et avec mes consoeurs
deborah claude et perrine tarneaud qui
nous rejoindrons tour à tour tout à
l'heure beaucoup de thèmes évidemment le
retour annoncé de nicolas sarkozy quand
et sur quel thème contre un retour
d'ailleurs contre lequel se mobilisent
certains de vos amis à l'ump on a vu ça
ce week-end on en parlera le bilan de
manuel valls que vous ciblez en
particulier comme ministre de
l'intérieur est également celui de
françois hollande sur le front du
chômage dont nous allons tout de suite
parlé brice hortefeux le chef de l'état
a admis ce mardi ne pas avoir réussi à
faire reculer le chômage en 2013 le pari
ou la promesse donc d'inverser la courbe
était audacieux faut-il aller jusqu'à
demander la démission de michel sapin le
ministre du travail comme comme le
demande jean françois copé dans mais
d'abord attendait il faut distinguer le
fond et la forme sur le fond
effectivement la situation est
épouvantable et le pré chef de l'état
avait annoncé qu'ils prenaient à paris
dermot je suis pas tellement pour les
paris en matière de responsabilité
publique
nous avons un ministère un ministre du
travail qui a fait de la propagande et
tout au long de ces derniers mois
annonçant l inversion et nous
aboutissons à des résultats qui sont des
résultats triplement catastrophique qui
sont catastrophés dans leurs données
brutes et ils sont catastrophiques quand
on regarde le nombre de chômeurs des
plus de 50 ans ils sont catastrophiques
quand on voit la situation des jeunes
qui se dans le taux de chômage est deux
fois et demie par exemple supérieur à
celui qui est enregistré en allemagne
jeudi soit la période
sur la période des résultats sont
absolument est catastrophique et la
comparaison avec l'allemagne et cruel
dans ce noble
les responsables gouvernementaux parler
de stabilisation vous dites c'est de la
propagande autorise également jeudi que
c'est exactement inverse de ce que dit
l'insee puisque l'insee annoncent une
détérioration au deuxième trimestre donc
celle inverse encore une fois de ce qui
est dit le volontarisme et c'est très
important en matière d'action publique
mais le déni des réalités c'est très
grave
donc il ya très important et très grave
et là on est dans le déni de réalité
parce que nous avions dit dans
l'opposition que hélas la politique qui
était mené dans notre pays en matière de
lutte contre le chômage
malgré l'injection de cent mille emplois
publics ce qui est extraordinaire
l'emploi extrêmement cher eh bien cela
ne pouvait pas marcher avec sa politique
de change hélas nous avons eu raison
j'aurais préféré que nous ayons torge
l'homme très sincères et vous avez noté
avons eu raison
l'inflexion donner à la politique que
vous dénoncez par françois hollande
lui-même louis l'éthique de l'offre il
et paris notamment bien sûr sur le
retour de la croissance est également
sur le pacte de responsabilité qu'il a
mis sur les rails alors pour premiers
éléments de ce qu'il en fait plus de
succès en 2014 selon vous avec cette
inflexion premier aimant doit-on faire
confiance à françois hollande
je suis comme saint thomas je crois que
ce que je vois
ils annoncent aujourd'hui très
exactement en fin il ya quelques jours
il a annoncé très exactement l'inversé
de ce qu'il a fait très exactement là
vers de ce qu'il a fait donc pardon
d'une angine à leurs enfants disent mot
pardon donc nous jugerons sur pièce pour
l'instant nous n'en savons rien et
deuxième élément est ce qu'une autre
politique aboutirait à d'autres
résultats fait un seul acte de
responsabilité la baisse des charges et
oui ça sur une fois je veux dire vous
voyez même voyons sur pièce moi ce que
j'observe c'est que et c'est d'ailleurs
très réconfortant parce que si on
d'élise le message uniquement sur le
thème record du chômage record
prélèvements obligatoires c'est à dire
d'un pot de cotisations et taxes record
des déficits records de la dette record
de la délinquance s'il on égrène tout
cela est malheureusement les chiffres
permettent de rappeler que ce ne sont
pas simplement des formulations de
l'opposition ce sont des réalités tout
ce que j'ai à dire tous ses records qui
sont arrêtés l'addition de ces records
c'est abouti à un record des chèques et
bien ce qui serait préoccupant c'est
s'il n'y avait pas de contre exemple
heureusement pour notre pays et il y à
des contre exemples
eh bien je pense à ce qui se passe dans
les pays qui sont nos principaux
partenaires et si vous observez
l'allemagne le taux de chômage en
allemagne est de 6,9 c'est à dire
presque la moitié presque pas tout à
fait pas la moitié exactement faire en
tous cas presque la moitié a rencontré
récemment l'aspirateur conseiller
conseils en tous cas presque la moitié
quand vous observez quant au royaume uni
qui était aussi un pays qui était en
souffrance
au royaume uni le chômage est tombé à
7,1 pour cent que sur les trois derniers
mois il y à 167/1000 chômeurs en moins
au royaume uni alors que chez nous avec
6 ou est très gentil vous dites se
stabilise en été ça s'aggrave donc vous
voyez bien qu'il ya une différence si
vous observez par exemple ce qui se
passe et en italie toujours pas du tout
moi c'est exactement l'inversé les au
contraire ça mais au congrès confiant
parce que je me dis qu'une autre
politique donnerait d'autres résultats
révèlent qu'ils s'attendaient à temps
des regards et les l'italie pour
compagne et à c'est pas des formules
c'est pas des slogans sont des réalités
en italie vous avez un déficit qui sera
limitée à 3%
pas du tout notre situation puisque la
commission européenne qui tourne bien
utile de temps en temps pour rappeler un
certain nombre de vérités nous allons
que ça sera à 3,8 fin 2009 en 2015 et
qu' il y aura un excédent commercial un
excédent commercial de 23 milliards
alors que nous avons un déficit
commercial de 70
des années et même cera mais ça veut
donc dire que la politique qui est menée
dans notre pays
abouti à une impasse ça veut dire que ce
n'est pas la bonne politique
et moi je dis observons ce qui se passe
autour de nous ce qui se passe en
allemagne ce qui se passe au royaume uni
ce qui se passe dans une certaine mesure
en italie ce qui se passe dans une
certaine mesure même si le taux de
chômage demeure extrêmement élevés en
espagne mais dans la situation assainie
sa venons dire qu'avec une autre
politique
nous aurons d'autres résultats et donc
la france qui aujourd'hui et s'enfonce
et capable de se redresser hortefeux ce
que vous êtes quand même noter qu'avec
la politique que présente aujourd'hui
françois hollande certains à l'ump sont
prêts à le suivre
y'a même jean pierre raffarin tiens qui
dit je suis prêt à voter la confiance si
si avec des si bien sûr si les économies
insulaires sont au rendez vous si des
baisses effectifs de charge le sont
également mais on ne sait jamais mais
que pensez vous de cette démarche de
jean pierre raffarin il n'a pas autant
d'à priori que voulait guy mollet
monnaie tu as mon sont très importants
le vainqueur de vote de confiance compte
ce qui compte c'est sur le fond je vous
dis je je suis convaincu que jean pierre
raffarin comme l'ensemble de la famille
ump ne demanderait qu'une seule chose
c'est que le gouvernement change
réellement de politique demandée c'est
que là c'est que ça marche je demande
qu'une seule chose c'est
qu'effectivement on aille concrètement
par exemple vous avez raison sur
l'allègement des charges l'entreprenant
l'histoire des contreparties pardon ça
n'a jamais fonctionné avant elle vous
pensez qu'on ne peut pas demander
légitimement du donnant-donnant j'ai
déjà demandé des contreparties chiffres
et aux entreprises
écoutez c'est un et toi c'est une vue de
l'esprit ou pour vous mettre toutes plus
posée c'est simplement un slogan c'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne mais en
revanche sur le fond qui est besoin
d'alléger rapidement fortement les
charges qui pèsent sur nos entreprises
oui non pardon on n'en prend pas le
chemin et reprenez prenez l'exemple de
l'imposition sur les sociétés nous avons
aujourd'hui le toit dit est ce qui est
le plus élevé d'europe le plus élevé
d'europe
nous avons deux pays en europe dont
royaume uni dont je parlais à l'instant
qui metz leur impôt sur les sociétés
morceaux écoutés nous faisons exactement
inverse donc si je vous dis ça marche
pas s'il ne change pas ce que vous voyez
dans l'objectif louable donc de créer de
l'emploi de la part de françois hollande
également une manoeuvre
tactique on a parlé de la triangulation
c'est à dire aller sur les terres de
l'adversaire mais ils avaient été
appelés à la méthode à l'estrie
également prêtés à nicolas sarkozy qui à
un braque connaît aussi un peu sur les
terres de gauche ce soit comme
thématique
non mais que françois hollande soit un
tacticien pour lui-même ça franchement
j'en ai jamais douté on a tous vu
l'occasion de la campagne interne au
parti socialiste où il était crédité de
3 % et 3 % auquel à ce rythme et il va
bientôt revenir des retraits honnêtement
mais ça technicien oui mais utile au
pays
franchement les résultats ne plaident
pas dans ce sens françois hollande a
évoqué en turquie la perspective
lointaine d'un référendum pour l'entrée
ou non de ce pays dans l'union que
pensez vous de cette idée tout cas
l'idée qui est une mauvaise idée c'est
de parler de l'adhésion de la turquie à
l'europe où une raison très simple
pardon peut-être très basique mais qui
me paraissait difficile de contredire
c'est que la turquie n'est pas dans le
continent européen voilà l'immense
majorité du territoire
non l'immense majorité du territoire
turc n'est pas sur le continent européen
donc c'est un élément de cet avis ce
sens puisque mon aventis atteint cette
année
il faut tenir compte s'agissant de la
construction européenne alors qui est
des partenariats qu'ils aient des liens
privilégiés qu'on essaie d'avoir des
relations qui soit extrêmement précises
fort dense commercial culturel bien sûr
c'est indispensable mais la question le
pays est-il en europe
ça a été tranché par la dérive des
continents la turquie ne fait pas partie
du continent européen
le chef d'état célibataire une situation
normale pour vous les dés lors que la
situation personnelle non plaide pas sur
l'exercice de la vie publique
franchement ce n'est pas notre sujet ce
qui était préoccupant c'est le côté
ridicule et c'était un peu effectivement
et
gênant et qu' il y ait après le ridicule
dans un autre domaine que nous avions
connu avec la petite leonarda qui
taclait en direct le président de la
république après sa conférence de presse
où on était franchement français
humiliés par cette attitude là le côté
pour résidents avec un casque noir
vissée sur la tête
c'était pas forcément glorieux vous avez
trouvé ça ridicule donc je pense que il
y avait un risque pour les français que
cela soit perçu comme ridicule
les heureux que cet épisode soit tournée
parce que cet épisode sentimentale qu'il
s'est donc tournée qui s'est refermée
maintenant marque la fin selon vous de
la notion de première dame
c'est par définition il ya les s'il en a
plus il peut y en avoir à nouveau
bientôt quatre ans première compagne
mais ce qu'il faut donner une existence
même dans les eaux écoutez-moi murs de
l'elysée je sais qu'on aime beaucoup
réglementé normalisée dans la machine
écoutez ça fonctionnait pas si mal donc
je suis pas pour on rajoute encore des
textes des normes sûr c'est sur ces
sujets très bien aller nous allons
évoquer maintenant le retour annoncé
tenez que la sarkozie avec nous c'est
vrai claude annoncé par certains par
bernadette chirac trahi le dis on
entendra dans un instant avant cela gros
plan sur d'autres come-back officialisé
cela ils font grincer des dents vie ce
sont vos camarades tête de liste ump
pour les élections européennes dans
certaines régions
marie brémaud et quentin calme et renaud
muselier nadine morano michèle
alliot-marie trois députés battu aux
dernières législatives quasi assuré
d'avoir une place au chaud au parlement
européen
la méthode passe mal auprès des
militants à demi-mot certains
responsables là vous c'est le fin ce
qu'ils nous disent
on nous dit alors les municipales c'est
bien on va voter pour un maire parce
qu'on le connaît c'est l'élection la
plus proche et les européennes c'est
l'élection la plus lointaine parce que
mais on a le stéréotype de on va recaler
ceux qui sont sains ses ministres ce qui
se retrouve en deuxième place font
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur c'est
le cas de françoise grossetête députée
sortante qui a dû céder sa place dans le
sud-est à un homme
renaud muselier c'est important aussi
d'avoir quelques candidats qui
permettent de rassembler justement
certaines sensibilités qui pourrait être
peut-être moins moi s'enthousiasme pour
aller voter pour des élections
européennes l'enthousiasmé européen il
n'est pas partagé par tous les cadres de
l'ump henri guaino ouvertement
eurosceptique est très remonté contre le
parachutage d'alain lamassoure du
sud-ouest en ile-de-france alain
lamassoure qui incarne à l'ump
l'europe fédéraliste dans ce choix la
tête de liste pour l'île de france
on a décidé délibérément de prendre le
risque d'affaiblir
l'ump et de la diviser je ne peux faire
autrement que d'en faire le constat
mais je vais m'efforcer en prenant sur
moi de ne pas affaiblir davantage ma
famille politique à l'ump il va donc
falloir trouver un compromis sur le
projet et sur ce qu'il ya derrière cette
ligne patriote et européen
un jeu d'équilibriste voilà d'abord à
claude de la fp2e rejoint bonsoir
d'abord à vos questions à brice
hortefeux sur l'ump y en a beaucoup en
question à poser il y en a beaucoup
alors on dit que il se murmure dans les
couloirs que les européennes ça va être
le top départ pour le retour de nicolas
sarkozy est ce que vous nous confirmer
cela
d'abord les européennes ce sera
l'occasion pour l'ump et d'afficher ses
ambitions des candidats j'ai écouté
leurs reportages
en réalité le reportage montre bien
combien il était difficile de critiquer
l'ump sur la préparation de ce scrutin
puisque précisément nous concilions à la
fois l'expérience le renouvellement
c'est à dire de nouvelles têtes de liste
et précisément des personnes
d'expérience derrière je lisais hier je
revenais précisément de bruxelles dans
le thalys qui le tgv qui relie bruxelles
à paris je lisais la presse et c'est
très intéressant il y avait il ya une
série d'articles sur le thème c'était
peu de renouvellement à l'ump et l'autre
dans d'autres journaux c'était l'ump a
assuré la continuité contrairement aux
autres fois où on changeait les députés
régulièrement juges sur cette esplanade
était quand même un peu difficile nos
casting s'est fait le marchand non pas
du tout bio mars a annoncé à neuilly et
puis ensuite je suis j'étais la
commission d'investiture j'ai participé
à ces instances je vous le dis on avait
annoncé vous aviez collectivement
annoncer quelque chose de très compliqué
et s'il ya quelque chose de compliqué
qui s'est passé c'est au parti
socialiste où il y a des recours sur
quasiment toutes les désignations des
têtes de liste et les dinos la colère
n'en reggae nous il est justement c'est
évoquer la personnalité
bah oui vous savez je vous le révèle pas
j'espère me dévouer tunnels sont chantés
sympathique original intéressant et
souvent colère mais aussi mais c'est
c'est peut-être dans les globules qu'il
a ça mais c'est une personnalité qui est
indépendante
donc je n'ai que la lame à s'emparer de
la question justement déterminer sur les
candidatures si la démonstration a été
faite d'abord qu'ils n'avaient pas de
vraies difficultés qu'une ça s'est fait
de dépenses sans délai je vous lis très
s'adorent il peut y avoir pourtant des
personnes comme ça mais pour les têtes
de liste ça s'est fait sans aucune
difficulté nous concilions des
personnalités qui ont une expérience
gouvernementale des personnalités qui
ont une grande expérience au parlement
européen le blabla qui est très facile à
la fois véhiculée par milieux politiques
et journalistiques que la france ne
compte pas au sein du parlement européen
juste un détail
le président du premier groupe au
parlement européen et français et le
président de la principale commission du
parlement p1 monsieur adam nassour est
effectivement français et on lui confie
la tête de lit dans la première région
de notre pays c'est dire comme on compte
leur troisième et atteint les troisième
élément sur la nécessité du
renouvellement dit sans arrêt les partis
politiques recase l'heure pas du tout et
je vais vous donner un exemple très
simple
étais je vous donne envie de vous donner
un exemple très simple nous faisons
progresser et jusqu'à présent il y avait
28 % des députés européens toutes
sensibilités confondues qui étaient là
pour trois mandats ces terres qui avait
quitté au troisième mandat qui avait eu
le temps de connaître d'appréhender de
maîtriser le mécanisme communautaire et
c'était 38% pour les allemands et 48%
49% pour les britanniques
nous rejoignons cette tendance donc nous
allons à la fois des députés qui sont
ancrées dans le fonctionnement
communautaire et combien c'est important
je vous le rappelle mais vous le savez
qu'aujourd'hui les deux tiers des deux
tiers de notre encadrement normatif
proviennent de bruxelles ces terres de
la commission du conseil et du parlement
donc c'est dire combien c'est important
sur le fond comment vous allez concilier
des positions qui sont parfois on
aimerait bien sûr c'est notre famille
est une famille de rassemblement ça
signifie quoi ça veut dire très
simplement pour la résumer il faudra
naturellement qu on le décline tout au
long de ces semaines qui sue c'est que
nous aimons l'europe mais nous l'aimons
tellement que nous considérons qu'il
faut la changer la faire évoluer la
modifie pas tout le monde va vous donner
raison à tout le monde
je pense qu'on est très raisonnable
c'est là qu'on ne peut pas on ne tire
pas un trait sur tout ce qui est là qui
européen
mais nous avons aussi conscience que
l'europe doit évoluer notamment dans
l'exercice de ses compétences il ya des
compétences que l'europe
à mon avis devrait rendre aux états il
ya des compétences plus forte que
l'europe devrait à chaleur vous êtes
confiant sur ces élections montrent que
le front national pourra y arriver
devant l'ump et le ps
oui et j'obtiens que front national dans
l' enquête d'opinion quel hacker match
de référence à diminuer m'écouter coup
c'est quand on se lance dans une
campagne électorale je pense qu'il faut
pas se préoccuper systématiquement des
autres il faut arriver avant ces prêts
vous préciser son programme et ses
convictions est question d'en faire et
puis après les français choisir s'ils
partent
ja par jour faisant beth cooper aucune
de pardon la langue française est riche
mais pascal ces trois qualificatifs les
miens je dis je le regrette je le
regrette parce que c'est vrai que ça
aurait été symbolique que nous puissions
partis ensemble comme nous l'avions fait
lorsque nicolas sarkozy était président
de la république et qu'il avait su
imposer cette unité est ce que vous avez
rama yade à ce sujet pour les
européennes on m'a dit ça c'est pas du
tout je n'ai pas à ma connaissance n'est
pas naturellement elle serait la
bienvenue c'est tout alors d'abord à
évoquer éventuellement le point de
départ de l'opération retour de nicolas
sarkozy avec celle de président de
l'association des amis nicolas sarkozy
qui annonce son retour et je vous le
disais donc dans la dette chirac secret
de polichinelle est dans la confidence
comme elle l'a révélé sur europe 1 bien
que l'invention le dire mais vous l'a
dit je vous dis je l'aï va me gronder 1
je ne pense pas de me dire ce qui vous a
dit je vous demande de me dire si vous a
dit servier ne va pas été intense et
revient au même on comprend que la
réponse est oui évidemment alors
évidemment brice hortefeux vous pouvez
me dire au risque d'être gronder mais
écoutez
bernadette chirac alors je n'ai que la
salle bernadette chirac a toujours eu de
l'affection de la complicité a toujours
exprimé de grande confiance et un grand
soutien a dit konaté donc peut-être
comment a t'elle interpréter ses
confidences comme répondant à ses
aspirations
ce n'est pas de l'humour corrézien mais
madame chirac comme vous le savez a
énormément d'humour
maintenant elle a parlé aussi d'elle pas
clair quand elle aime mais elle parle
aussi précis quand elle déteste alors du
retour de nicolas sarkozy il en a été
question ce rite aid au conseil national
de l'ump peut parler vie on dit et on a
beaucoup parlé des primaires avec
l'organisation d'une haute autorité avec
des sages voilà donc la question le
processus est installé le processus est
lancé il y aura une primaire tous les
ténors de l'ump ont l'air assez d'accord
sur cette question qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
passé ailleurs de que ça se consoler
avec toute une série de ce cru de vote
scrutin de consultation des cadres de
l'ump
et ça s'est passé comme vous c'est
l'ensemble avait pas eu notamment pour
l'élection du bureau politique et
l'instance statutaire de notre famille
politique il ya un accord qui est
intervenante en entre nous tous et tout
s'est très bien déroulé la prime est
maintenant sur la primaire il y a eu un
décision lors de la commission de
révision des statuts met en place ces
primaires je vous précise d'ailleurs que
je faisais partie de cette commission et
que j'ai indiqué que je ne m'y étais pas
opposer jeu mais je n'étais pas au
processus puisse être arrêté s'il
revient et coûte cher alors si ça vient
candidat qui est à 60% indiscutable
alors je ce que je vous disais
simplement c'est que j'ai voté le
principe de ces primaires mais que je
considère que l'on ne peut pas écarter
d'un revers de main ce que jean pierre
raffarin ou henri guaino et 10 sur ce
sujet notamment quand il rappelle l'un
et l'autre avec leur vocabulaire et
leurs mots que ce n'est pas dans la
tradition de la vème république ou que
ce n'est pas dans la tradition et
gaullistes comme de la lauriers comme le
dit henry eto'o voilà et à ce stade je
ne mentirai d'ailleurs pas plus qu'en
mai lorsque le dire s'il ya des sondages
très favorables à nicolas sarkozy à son
retour les 120 seront plus forts que la
démocratie interne
si c'est vous qui le dites je pose la
question non lorsqu'on est présenté
comme une affirmation les eaux que la
démocratie
nous n'en sommes pas là je vous répète
encore une fois précise les choses
le mp adopté les primaires et moi-même
dans la commission des statuts je n'y
étais pas opposé simultanément je
n'écarte pas d'un revers de main ce que
disent les anciens premier jean-pierre
raffarin ou la personnalité d'un four
personnalité qui est henri guaino et je
dit nous verrons bien le monde alors que
dites-vous de françois fillon françois
fillon il dit attention si ya pas de
primaires il va y avoir division à
droite y aura plusieurs candidats de
l'ump et donc on risque bien de laisser
passer le front national au second tour
à la prochaine présidentielle
pensez vous c'est une menace de françois
fillon mais c'est sa conviction c'est
parfaitement son droit de l'exprimer
cela ne me choque en rien simplement
nous sommes juste au tout début de 2014
vous verrons bien quelle est la
situation le moment venu je vous dis je
vous irez capituler mon sentiment en ce
début d'année 2014
donnons nous rendez vous plus tard
lorsque la question réellement de la
préparation de l'élection présidentielle
sera lent
je pensais que vous allez nous parler
que lorsque la question du retour
effectif de nicolas sarkozy vient se
poser c'est si bien tout peu plus de 35
ans si je ne m'abuse sam amick plus de
35 ans agit pas hélas parce que ça fait
longtemps que je connais c'est plus de
13 on a du mal à imaginer qu'il aille à
une primaire mais très sincèrement je ce
n'est pas son sujet voilà donc pas vous
dire plus c'est pas son sujet c'est le
poisson suis président j'avais dit
attendez j'avais dit alors c'est
malheureusement je suis obligé de me
répéter pardonnez moi mais j'ai aimé la
primaire pour lui c'est secondaire
voilà et je n'ai pas changé d'avis c'est
comme si je les considère qu'il peut et
ne doit s'en dispenser quand ce n'est
pas son sujet donc je ne sais pas quel
est son sentiment sur ce point je ne
sais pas son sujet il n'est pas dans la
vie politique qui est national ce n'est
pas son sujet mais vous voyez assez
régulièrement il consulte beaucoup ils
voient des députés et non mais qui suis
très impliqué son sujet n'intervient pas
comme vous l'avez observé dans la vie
politique quotidienne nationale depuis
2012 donne pas d'interview fait pas
meeting de ne pas sortir il l'a fait une
fois sur un sujet très précis dans deux
directement il a fait une fusée raison
une fois sur le sujet international
parce qu'il trouvait que la france était
quand même très pas sinistré les bras
ballants sur la question syrienne
il est intervenu une deuxième fois quand
il ya eu la décision du conseil
constitutionnel est sûre
sur le plafonnement des préjugés ou non
et oui je crois je ne veux pas enfin je
pense je peux pas vous répondre très bas
des allées tellement fait j'imagine que
s'il y avait eu un problème ça se serait
su d'obstacles judiciaires pour le
retour de nicolas sarkozy une enquête
préliminaire mais oui la suite de la
décision
en fait ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est
une réflexion que ce que je que je vous
fais d'ailleurs que avoue un diviseur
mais collectivement mais aussi avoué dur
ça il ya eu toute une histoire notamment
sur ce qu'on a appelé la sphère karachi
je n'y reviens pas dans les détails
franchement son nom a été avancé évoqué
souligné surligner institude il y a eu
une décision si on a totalement exonéré
sur ce sujet ça fait 2000 personnes m'en
a rien d'autre
c'est sans doute la règle mais mais
c'est quelque chose de très désagréable
sujet dont on va parler france 3 va
diffuser ce mercredi une interview du
colonel kadhafi
réalisée en 2011 dans laquelle il
affirme avoir financé la première
campagne de nicolas sarkozy
il s'exprime elle a quatre jours avant
les premières frappes occidentales
que pensez-vous de l'aria nouveau séduit
on l'entend les routes non mais tu
n'avances pas de preuve mais oui mais
attendez ça attendez vous j'ai déjanté
menacer plus d'actualité c'est
d'histoire vous faites bien bien sûr
qu'il avait évoqué cela mais franchement
il est qu'ils répondent ilan qu'il
répond à une demande de soutien
financier mais attendez et
sous décision de vos qualités mentales
et je suis venu de toute déclaration tu
vas mais ce que ça vous y pouvait
imaginer simplement pour juste la
question que quelqu'un qui est sur le
point d'être renversée et qu'ils
allaient perdre l'autorité le prestige
les moyens le statut à les remercier
ce la france essentiellement et les et
le royaume uni à les remercier
ce qui mettait fin à sa dictature
faisant des maux de gorge attendait
est-ce que je vous prendrai pas question
très simple tous les trois ans encore
une fois
mettez vous à la place de dignitaires
d'un régime dictatorial qui allait être
renversée par l'action de la france
franchement il n'allait pas encourager
et dire merci et bravo pour vous rien de
nouveau écoutez on l'avait déjà vu à ma
connaissance où on va je crois vous
l'association des amis nicolas sarkozy
serait unie je crois à demain vous allez
déjeuner vous dites je voyais trailer
sur votre site que les adhésions se
multiplient comment ça fonctionne pour
gagner vous justement c c'est une
association c'est pas un parti politique
c'est pas un courant et j'avais
d'ailleurs annoncé que nous allions
décliner cela l'échelon local et l'otan
régionale et nous avions d'ailleurs nous
n'étions prêts ils nous envisagions de
l'indiquer mais comme cela s'est su
depuis nous vous nous considérons que
le temps qui souffre c'est le temps des
élections municipales et européennes et
donc c'est le temps des parties et donc
nous n'allons pas ajouter une structure
à d'autres structures
en revanche oui nous nous réunissons
demain que nous faisons est
régulièrement et voit un endroit qui
s'appelle l' entre amis parce que c'est
ça c'est un élan d'amitié dessus
fidélité de reconnaissance très bien
qu'est ce que vous avez
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter à nicolas
sarkozy pour son anniversaire il a 59
ans ce mardi
aujourd'hui et c'est aujourd'hui on le
fait à l'heure pour lui souhaiter quoi
et on lui souhaite bon je lui souhaite
d'abord avec beaucoup d'affection bien
faire mais je lui souhaite de rester tel
qu'il est voilà d'accord encore un
mauvais ce que vous souhaiter la
victoire de françois bayrou aux
municipales à pau oui ou non
je souhaite qu'ils aient une alternance
à pau puisque et c'est votre candidat il
n'y a pas eu d'investiture qui était
donnée m'embêter je souhaite
l'alternance
il n'y a pas de solution dans cette
ville je souhaite la terre dans cette
ville comme dans les autres villes qui
sont détenus aujourd'hui par deux partis
social quand même à quand il s'agit de
françois bayrou que nous avons échappé
merci au public cela arrive maintenant
juste après cette enquête de jérôme
navier sur manuel valls dans le modèle
dit on parfois et nicolas sarkozy place
beauvau mais pourquoi aujourd'hui plus
particulièrement le ministre de
l'intérieur devient une cible
prioritaire dé l'ump comme on l'a encore
vu ce week end
monsieur valls donne des coups de menton
bondi sur chaque fait divers exploite à
son profit chaque polémique critique ses
prédécesseurs si le nom de manuel valls
n'avait pas été prononcé la description
est également pu coller à nicolas
sarkozy du temps où il était placé
beauvau même activis même propension à
imposer leur rythme aux médias même
volonté de voir plus loin
ou plutôt de l'autre côté de la rue où
se trouvent les
mais confrontés aux chiffres de la
délinquance qui ne sont pas bons le
ministre de l'intérieur touche désormais
aux limites de sa méthode
surtout après avoir pris des risques sur
des sujets polémiques après les
polémiques sur les roms la sphère
leonarda la sphère dieudonné il ya le
sentiment que au lieu de s'installer
dans la communication de l'action manuel
valls installe dans les polémiques dans
les polémiques qui divisent les français
et surtout qui divise la gauche est
encore pire qui divise le ps donc
aujourd'hui clairement manuel valls a un
problème pour rebondir politiquement son
nouveau cheval de bataille la lutte
contre l'extrême droite même s'il s'en
défend c'est bien une tournée anti fn
qui l'a amené à hénin-beaumont la
semaine dernière mais là encore il se
heurte aux résultats sur la délinquance
le parti frontiste n'hésite pas à parler
d'un ministre en campagne aux frais des
contribuables
oui en la sécurité en france le front
national le ministre le plus populaire
du gouvernement manuel valls est
actuellement confronté à une chute de 6
à 8 points dans les derniers sondages
mais dans son entourage on défend sa
méthode un ministre de l'intérieur qui
est sur les territoires au quotidien
avec les français depuis deux ans nous
avons installé avec le ministre de
l'intérieur des zones de sécurité
prioritaire
plus de 60 aujourd'hui presque 80 qui
démontre que cela réussisse et que par
tous et dsp existe le taux de
délinquance diminue
manuel valls le sait la sécurité est une
des priorités des français
donc pas question d'abandonner ce
terrain à la droite ou à l'extrême
droite
pour le ministre qui rêvent un jour
d'accéder au sommet de l'état également
les mauvais chiffres de la délinquance
un des volets de découvrir l'âge entame
en publié
montre les limites de la méthode de main
de manuel valls oui je l'avais
d'ailleurs prévu est évoqué au début
dans le scepticisme général de personnes
à l'espace est pas l'individu la
personnalité manuel valls qui est en
cause c'est la politique d'un
gouvernement
et pourquoi parce que lorsque l'on
exerce les responsabilités de la
sécurité de nos concitoyens c'est à dire
l'intérieur et la justice et que l'on
dit la politique des résultats s'est
terminée ça ne compte pas c'est plus
notre sujet si si c'est très exactement
ce qu'il a dit c'est lui il appelait ça
la politique du chiffre
j'ai appris ça petit des résultats de la
politique du chiffre c'est fini moi
jveux dire donc j'ai compris la
politique d'hier elle ça c'est fini
et ensuite quand on dit que de toute
manière lorsqu'on est condamnée jusqu'à
cinq années de prison tout mais on n'est
pas obligé d'en faire une seule journée
eh bien je dis ça mais dites vous bien
c'est là vous voyez peut-être que là une
différence entre vous et moi sur ce plan
c'est que et vous pensez ou partaient
d'un présupposé c'est que le délinquant
ne connais pas ces sujets-là discuter je
vous encourage à le faire avec les
responsables par exemple des police aux
frontières et dans les aéroports ou avec
les responsables de la gendarmerie quand
ils interpellent un délinquant
ils sont frappés par le fait qu'il
connaisse très exactement
l'évolution de la politique qui est
menée en matière pénale par exemple on
peut dire que le bilan ne fait plus peur
non ça veut dire qu'ils savent que de
toute manière il serait cette chance
qu'ils échapperont donc le conjugue
azoulay des mains de probation la
conjugaison des deux précisément abouti
à une détérioration la délinquance mais
je veux pas être caricatural et bien
évidemment nos sociétés deviennent de
plus en plus compliqué de plus en plus
violentes c'est pour ça que nous avions
proposée et nous avions imaginé une
réforme par exemple de l' ordonnance de
1945 sur les mineurs
parce que nous considérons que la
délinquance des mineurs
aujourd'hui n'est pas la même que celle
qui était exactement au lendemain de la
une guerre mondiale celle là était
récent marty fait il a été décerné
dimanche et il a été décidé que l'on ne
toucherait pas à l' ordonnance de 1945
sur les mineurs je le dis sincèrement je
pense que c'est une erreur
je vous donne un autre exemple mais je
sais ça dans une démocratie en matière
de politique migratoire
le gouvernement considère que l'accès à
la nationalité
c'est le départ d'un parcours
d'intégration eh bien nous dans
l'opposition et je sais ce sujet que je
connais un peu mieux parce que je les ai
exercé à la fois l'immigration est
l'intérêt nous considérons exactement
inverse c'est à dire que l'accès à la
nationalité ça doit être l'aboutissement
du parcours d'intégration
c'est une conversation que j'ai eue avec
le ministre de l'intérieur qui a tenté
de convaincre qu'on n'était pas si
éloigné d'un casino dans les maux de
tête mais dans la réalité si et bien ce
qui apparaît aujourd'hui c'est la
différence entre les mots qui sont forts
les actes qui sont faibles et la
conséquence de tout ça
c'est une délinquance qui se dégradent
situation la délinquance qui se dégrade
mais quand on entend françois fillon
parlait de la méthode de manuel valls on
l'a vu dans le reportage on a
l'impression qu'il fait allusion
quelqu'un qu'il connaît bien
est-ce que vous avez l'impression quand
même que parfois manuel valls et
l'enfant politique de nicolas sarkozy
mais ça la met dans la façon de faire
oui vous savez c'est pas comme ça la
politique
l'action publique c'est pas ça bien sûr
que les bosses à compte bien sûr que les
postures ça compte bien sûr que le style
ça compte mais il ya une grande
différence entre ce qui a été menée par
nicolas sarkozy et ce qui est menée par
le gouvernement actuel
c'est clair que le gouvernement a trouvé
ses limites c'était une grande
différence c'est que dans un cas il y
avait des résultats et d'un lothian n'a
pas géré on a l'air de découvrir depuis
huit jours fériés
ces résultats n'ont pas du tout
l'observatoire nationale de pardon de
vous lire si c'était moi qui vous
il a débuté en 2008 2007 façon raisonnée
collation attendait si c'est moi qui
vous le dis vous n'êtes pas obligés de
me croire et d'ailleurs je sais pas
pourquoi je sens vous me croyez pas
beaucoup mais en revanche aux revanches
absolument mais en revanche quand vous
avez l'observatoire indépendant de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
c'est un observatoire indépendant qui
dit noir sur blanc que de 2007 à 2011
la délinquance a globalement diminué
dans notre pays
quel est remonté en 2012 et qu'elle
s'est aggravée en 2013 ce qui est
exactement dit alors qu'ils nous aurions
celui-là siens d'europe centrale et la
mise en place ou manuel valls dit les
reconduites à la frontière sont aussi
nombreuse je suis très actif sur ce
front là dit il un pas du tout c
diminuent là aussi ça diminue blessé à
ce parti pour les observe pour les
intimes pour les points les
observatoires pour l'observatoire s'est
clairement indiqué qu'effectivement il
ya une évolution ya une augmentation de
14% de naturalisation une augmentation
de 40 milles des régularisations et une
diminution est de 40% des retours on va
écouter ça c'est alors qu'une fois c'est
pas moi qui le dit mais tout ça pour
dire que en politique et qu'il faut
faire aussi très attention attention aux
mots attention aux postures un quart et
un âgisme ajustement des mots qui sont
forts la république la sécurité de tous
le droit ou des citoyens quand ça ne
suis pas un moment donné ça apparaît est
pourri c'est ce qui est en train
d'apparaître
et pourtant manuel valls et mouiller sa
chemise dans des combats on l'a vu sur
la sphère dieudonné on voit aussi contre
le front national il décide de faire
campagne ville par ville pour les
élections municipales contre le front
national donc sur le terrain ils nous
ont mis sa chute le rapprochement sur la
sphère du neige comme ça tu vas faire
dieudonné j'avais dit que le combat
était juste mais que les bases
juridiques étaient faibles réseau
vêtements
je pense pas me tromper parce que si on
était allé au bout d'un processus
rédactionnel et conforter m'enfin on
n'est pas allé en août parce que
attention s'il en va dans la cour
européenne de justice c'est bon
j'imagine que là sans doute ce que je
vous dis aujourd'hui serait peut-être
conforté j'avais dit les bases
juridiques sont faibles et on a vu qu'il
ya une contradiction failli de
contradictions il ya eu des différentes
jument quelques heures assure sur ce sur
ce sujet mais attention à ce que la les
à certaines attitudes n'aboutisse pas à
faire de la publicité
voilà donc je pense qu'il est utile de
bien avoir cela en mémoire la
gesticulation je dis pas ça pour manuel
valls particulièrement jeudi manière
j'ai la gesticulation peu abouti à
l'effet inverse et se monte à la
nationalité française mais il ya une
question qui revient dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui père aimant faire le djihad
en syrie est ce que quand ils ont une
double nationalité
vous demandez peut-être à ce qu'ils
soient déchus de leur nationalité
française
c'est un sujet très compliqué qui
concerne beaucoup de monde sait ça
d'ailleurs la préoccupation puisque l'on
estime qu'ils avaient ce 'très
difficile' les instants oui au niveau
européen on estime que c'est peut être
entre deux et quatre mille c'est ce qui
est indiqué bon donc ce sont pas des
chiffres minima ce sont des chiffres
extrêmement important ce qui me
préoccupe d'abord c'est le suivi de ces
jeunes il faut qu'il y ait un suivi la
pente au service de renseignements je
rappelle d'ailleurs aux services de
renseignement sont très performants
puisque je ne sais pas qu'il ya
statistiques aujourd'hui mais lorsque
j'étais ministre de l'intérieur et sur
cette période plus large du quinquennat
on déjoue est presque deux attentats sur
notre territoire par an donnez donc je
souhaite qu'il y ait un suivi
et si possible une anticipation
vitesse il bascule dans la réalisation
très jeune c'est pour cela que on doit
impérativement progresser et dans ma
derniers moyens techniques
technologiques scientifiques à quelques
lampes au lycée passe et plus il soit
question quand on les rattrape en
turquie ou en acier et qu'il revienne en
france à ce qu'il faut prendre d'abord
eu tant d'erreurs qui entend de ces deux
jeunes
j'imagine que pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux ils sont nés sur le
territoire français qui l'ont six ans le
16 ou 18 ans et qui sont donc la
nationalité française du fait du droit
du sol donc c'est quelque chose qui est
assez compliquée en plus à contester
comme de surcroît vous le savez aussi
dans certains dans les pays du maghreb
le principe c'est la double nationalité
donc quand une fois y ait une base
juridique est très qui là aussi très
incertain mais c'est plus que je
comprends votre question mais où est ce
que ça vous avions utilisé le plus
il y avait une base juridique est une
base juridique incertaine donc avant
d'avancer surgit de votre expérience
j'avais émis un souhait et c'est ma
seule amie prennent acte du fait que
c'était juridiquement très compliqué ce
qui n'enlève rien aux souhaits qui
étaient exprimées donc examinons les
bases juridiques manque une fois ce qui
me préoccupe le plus c'est le suivi de
ces jeunes aient la capacité
d'anticipation en ayant les déceler en
pouvant l'aider ce thé dans les milieux
associatif éducatif et de dernière
minute de dernière minute ce qui est
préoccupant aussi c'est la
radicalisation de certains esprits de la
société on a pu le voir dimanche dernier
avec le jour de la colère qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette manifestation
dont le seul point commun dans
l'impression simple à haine des juifs
oui c'était enfin j'ai pas peut-être que
j'ai pas suffisamment suis je vous le
dis ce que j'ai vraiment j'ai été très
impressionné mais chedjou
globalement les chinois police m'ont
peut-être mais disons qu'ils avaient
visé j'ai vu qu'ils revendiquent et 159
la police 17 mais disons que ce soit en
tout cas je pense je suis le grand t
d'abord ça va continuer attendez j'ai
d'abord été impressionné par la
mobilisation je m'attendais une
manifestation hors mobilisation
syndicale partisane est institué avec et
1500 personnes
non c'est pas ça et ça veut dire quoi
et au delà ça veut dire sans doute que
eu un désengagement finalement de
françois hollande l'a aussi battu en
brèche et nous avons une france qui est
aujourd'hui une france déchirée
parce qu'une france excédé c'est cela
qui est d'accord oui excédés et qui donc
connais peut-être des dérives alors de
parmi les gens qui étaient là j'imagine
qu'il y en avait qui étaient ceux qui
étaient majoritairement parce que
violemment hostiles à françois hollande
est pour la politique était mené mais se
sont mobilisés or toute consigne
partisane syndicats les autres et puis
naturellement des éléments extrémistes
blancs des intérêts des éléments
d'interpellations pour vous donner pour
vous donner un ordre de grandeur qui
vous permet de comprendre par exemple
dans la nuit la saint sylvestre en 2010
dans deux pendants de 2010 à 2011
il y avait 100 personnes qui a été
interpellé dans les syndicats 260
signifie qu'ils avaient déterminé
tension merci brice hortefeux c'est un
vrai sujet ça ne peut se faire que avec
la consultation des populations juin pas
que ça puisse se faire sans la
consultation aux populations avant
jamais il faut le faire on séparer votre
avis il faut le faire il faut faire dans
l'intérêt des administrés des habitants
donc ce sont deux conditions qu'on me
démontre l'intérêt est de s'asseoir avec
l'assentiment des populations une grande
gueule
merci merci merci bonsoir à tous et à
très vite heures
mocratie visite
liberté égalité